tucked away in North turkeys mountains
is a remote village where some residents
speak a special language this is kushti
lee also known as the bird language it
allows complex conversations over long
distances without using words this great
big story is inspired by Genesis mothers
go check them would believe could wound
unbearable in mad says is known as the
greatest Whistler in her village for
centuries farmers in cusco have kept
livestock and produced various crops
they originally began using the bird
language so they could quickly
communicate with each other over the
hills while they worked well you'll
build one inshallah you Harrison enough
Avenue Jenny one another drop passing
the baby Nagano Japan are young and even
they give they need a narrator are
kibosh Inga wanna see I know Lana Rosen
Mustafa similar to Morse code the bird
language transforms the full Turkish
vocabulary into varied pitch frequencies
and melodic lines what a Mach number my
there should be how much barnacle Adam
Colin Chicago says it bula future calm
environment in Joe
didn't charge on the broad indexical
sensing in the Saskatoon de thomas miss
a Vietnam occurrences Jacques Nasser
fear a fear about rockets in their
sang-mook but among layovers money she
England Buddha but the bird language is
slowly disappearing I sure got it Kumi
they usually she said lift up on the
tree with Delia telephone
she got nine get it chopped what urban
honey I wanna show you a lot but man
says his whistling is still going strong
honey I shot Maggie street with dilemmas
venom an offical student be Muslim given
an in-depth look Tanya miracle ambition
savvy room on it Sammy added a under him
[Music]